from the return of pif we go to the
reopening of the big
tent after more than seven months
absinthe at caesar's palace is back
tomorrow night
and here to tell us about the latest
updates with the show is producer
ross mollison hey ross how are you jc
i'm fantastic how's it going awesome so
happy you guys are back and so what
changes have you made to the show
and to the venue so you guys could
reopen
well the venue was 660 seats we've cut
it down to 153 seats
everybody is sitting at these awesome
cabaret tables and you can order
incredible champagne or or a cocktail or
a bottle of water whatever you need
and sit and enjoy the show and watch it
we're applying all the governor's rules
the whole thing is going to be socially
safely separated
and the foyer outside uh is
the foyer is actually outside under the
absent electric oak i just heard some
music play there yeah we have we have
some
footage of the show i mean it's such a
classic vegas show we love the show
so is it still in the round or you guys
are now kind of spreading the show out a
little bit more
yeah we're still in the round it's
spread out a bit but everybody's at
their own little seat uh their own
little table
and then there's a kind of a a 25 foot
distance from the stage and then
everything happens up there on the stage
and you know we're hoping the gazillion
air comes
uh he's been locked down at caesar's
palace for seven months now
i haven't actually seen him yet but uh
we'll find out on wednesday night
whether he shows up or not
we'll see does the gazillionaire have
any surprises up his sleeve for for the
premiere of the show tomorrow night
yeah the enormous surprise will be
whether he actually shows up or not
because you know i've been over to his
suite i've banged on the door i've
called him he hasn't answered the phone
you know i mean he's i guess it sounds
like he's a bit like
the magic dragon he's just been totally
locked down in his suite there but
you know all the big openings are
happening i know we've got circa tonight
then tomorrow night we've got absinthe
followed by pip the magic dragon it
doesn't get any bigger this is we're
very excited las vegas is starting to
return here how do we get tickets to the
show how do we take us absent
spiegelworld.com i think you want to get
in quick that
the tickets are selling like hotcakes
there so you want to get in quick if you
want to come down and see it
i think we're selling into we've got
some tickets left for next week
uh it starts on wednesday night and then
we're playing 10 shows a week
and our aim is to get back and stay back
and do it safely so everybody can come
and have a great time
we love it ross thank you so much we're
so happy you guys are back and we'll see
you down there at the tent
again to get tickets to absent just go
to spiegelworld.com and las vegas now we
will be